one piece is one of the greatest stories  of all time monkey d luffy is the man  who will become the king of the pirates  when luffy was still a child in the sea  called east blue he idealized a pirate  named red hair shanks he dreamed of  adventuring just like his hero one day  and when shanks set sail he refused to  take the young luffy with him but gave  him his straw hat as a keepsake luffy  turned promised to become a great pirate  and return the hat to shanks one day  then luffy finally followed in the  footsteps of shanks and of his older  brother ace he gathered a crew and set  sail for the grand land the most  dangerous sea in the world in order to  find the fabled treasure the one piece  he still hasn't reunited with shanks but  since then luffy has toppled warlords of  the sea declared war against the world  government and has become one of the  greatest pirates of the world but this  really shouldn't be a surprise because